ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
OKAY HAND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA MICROPHONE VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN QUINN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH. STONE TUNING
CALAVERAS VEHICLE TO OUR VOEPEL
WALDRON LORD WEBER WICKS. WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS EIGHT
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT AND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS. IN THE REAR
THE CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. HOW MONNING
ARE. TODAY IN THIS CHAMBER ARE
THE ELECTED MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. THEY
ARE READY TO PERFORM THEIR
DUTIES GOD. PLEASE GUIDE THEM IN
THEIR THOUGHTS AND ACTIONS. SO
THEY PICK SO THAT THEY CAN
ACHIEVE THE GREATEST GOOD FOR
ALL. MAY ALL BE HAPPY. MAY ALL
BE FREE FROM DISEASE. MAY ALL
REALIZE WHAT IS A GOOD. MAY NOT
BE SUBJECT TO MISERY. PCB ON TO
ALL ON ME. THANK YOU MARIO SURE
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
DR ARAMBULA AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE. DOCTORATE PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. IT IS A
LITTLE. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY TRIM SACRAMENTO
MONDAY FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
BENNETT ONE PM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE IF
YOU SIMPLY PRESIDING CHIEF LOOKS
TO PROGRAM A DESPERATE CLERK
DAVID BOWMAN REYES RAMOS MOVES
AND MISTER FLORA SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AMPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVIE TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE THREE EXCUSED ABSENCES TODAY
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE WALDRON
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REGGIE JONES SAWYER FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL
WORK. AMS REYES YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WEBER AND SEE
OUR TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN H. HELLO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE
HAVE GUESTS WITH US TODAY
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUESTS WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR TANG IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AT MY DESK MISTER
CHANG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SPEAKER IN ORDER TO PRESENT HERE
MOST RECENTLY RETIRED INSPECTOR
GENERAL MR ROY WESLEY FROM OUR
CORRECTION SYSTEM. I HAVE TO SAY
WHEN I RAN FOR OFFICE A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO I DIDN'T COME UP TO
SACRAMENTO. TO TACKLE THE
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM WILL REALLY
TO REFORM IT BUT ON A ON A DAY
WHEN I HAPPENED TO STUMBLE INTO
OUR BUDGET SUB FIVE HEARING.
MISTER WESLEY WAS- PRESENTING
HIS FINDINGS OF WHAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING AT SALINAS VALLEY ONE
OF ARCH MORE CHALLENGING
FACILITIES. REALLY SORT OF SHOOK
ME UP AND ROCKED ME TO MY CORE
REGARDING HOW NEEDED OUR JOB IS
TO HAVE BETTER OVERSIGHT OVER
OUR CORRECTION SYSTEM IF YOU'RE
SAFE OVER FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS SYSTEM. AND STOPPING
WITH WITH THOUSANDS OF STUFF IN
ALMOST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
INMATES. PEOPLE WHO REALLY HAVE
NO VOICE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
CANNOT IMPACT THE SYSTEM AND
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
MISTER WESLEY AND REALLY WITH
HIS RUNNING OF THE OFFICES AS WE
WERE TALKING EARLIER TODAY. HE
SIMPLY WAS DOING WHAT WE ALL
HOPE TO DO WHICH IS TO TRY TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT. RUN BETTER. AND
FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE HAD THE
HONOR TO HEAR HIS PRESENTATION
AND BUDGETS OF FIVE. HE'S A VERY
IMPARTIAL OBJECTIVE VIEWER OF
THAT DEPARTMENT. ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
MAKE IT BETTER. TO MAKE IT MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HOW WE COULD BETTER
USE OUR DOLLARS AND- HOW WE
COULD REALLY. REALLY IMPROVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS SO CRITICAL TO
ENTIRE STATE FOR ALL FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. THAT I KNOW THAT
I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL THE MEMBERS
OF A BUDGETS OF FIVE TO. A FINE
THAT HUGHES REPORTS. VERY FAIR.
AND VERY- VERY FULL OF FACTS AND
INFORMATION. AND I PERSONALLY AM
VERY VERY SAD TO GO HE
PERSONIFIES. WHAT IT IS TO BE A
PUBLIC SERVANT HE SERVED FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS AND INSPECTOR
GENERAL. DEPARTMENT BUT PRIOR TO
THAT HE SERVED OUR COUNTRY IN
THE MILITARY. AND THE AIR FORCE
AS WELL AS IN THE NAVY- SHE
REALLY HAS EARNED. THIS RETARDED
BUT I AM PERSONALLY. A VERY SAD
TO SEE HIM GO. BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT IN HIS SHORT TIME. AS
EXPECTED GENERAL HE REALLY.
HELPED SHAPE THE DISCOURSE IN
THE STATE DISCOURSE IN
SACRAMENTO. ABOUT REALLY WHAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO MAKE OUR
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM. SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
CURRENT INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO IS
ALSO HERE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
AMERYKAH SAYING WHO'S ALSO HERE.
ALL WHO IS OUR WHO'S OUR NEW
INSPECTOR GENERAL VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
BUT IT REALLY IS MY DISTINCT
HONOR JUST TO. RISE AND JUST
HONOR IN AMAZING- PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO IS ARE. YOU MAKES
ME PROUD TO BE A CALIFORNIA SOME. AND MISS GARCIA YOU TWO ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I ALSO
RISE- WITH BOTH- A LOT OF
GRATITUDE BUT ALSO SEND THIS ON
THE RETIREMENT OF MR WESLEY
CALIFORNIA HAS THIRTY THREE A
STATE PRESENCE ACROSS THE STATE
IN A SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL SPENDING WITH NEARLY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND INCARCERATED
PEOPLE NOT ONLY THE LARGEST
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY IT'S ALSO
ONE OF THE MOST COMPLICATED. AS
THE CHERUB WHICH IS A FIVE A
PUBLIC SAFETY EVERY LIGHT ON THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL OFFICE TO
SERVE AS THE ICE IN THE YEARS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
CRITICAL DECISIONS ON
INVESTMENTS THAT IMPACT THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE LIVING AND
WORKING INTO. PRESENCE I'M
ESPECIALLY BEING APPRECIATIVE OF
THE COVE IN NINETEEN MONITORING
IN THE PRESENCE THAT MISTER
WESLEY AND HIS LAPTOP PERFORMED
INFORMATION WAS CRITICAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO FILL ITS DUTIES
OF OVERSIGHT. THIS WEST IS A PRO
AS- I GENERAL HAS. BEEN A
SOLUTION. APPROACH APPROACHES
DUTIES WITH PERRIN AND INTEGRITY
AND PROFESSIONALISM. THIS JOB
DEFINITELY WASN'T AN EASY ONE
BUT HE WAS STEADFAST IN HIS
COMMITMENT TO FULFILL HIS
DUTIES. AND OBLIGATION UNTIL
ALONG. AND SOMEONE I THANK HIM
FOR HIS- TIME OF SERVICE- TO THE
STATE AND WISH HIM WELL IN HIS
RETIREMENT. I'M JUST THINKING
THAT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE FOR THE WITH
THEM YOU BRING BROUGHT IN AND
THE STEADFASTNESS OF YOUR BODY
AND TO MAKE SURE. WE'RE DOING-
IS BEST AND FAIR FOR THE SYSTEM
AS A WHOLE. YOUR SERVICE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MOVING TO CONCURRENCE IN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS. WE
ARE AT CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT THE CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT IMMACULATELY TO STATE
GOVERNMENT DECLARING THE YEARS
HEATER UP THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY. MR RODRIGUEZ YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK ROBERT
290% AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS REQUIRES CAROL
YES TO STOP IS A STATE WIDE.
DONATION SYSTEM RATHER THAN A
STATEWIDE REGISTRY AND PROVIDE
CERTAIN CIVIL LIABILITY
EXEMPTIONS TO PROVIDE TO PRIVATE
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS USING THE SYSTEM I
RESPECT OUT FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL. IS THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL. CHAU
VOTE I SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. BARKIN CURTIN. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO WILL BE
CONTINUED FILE ITEMS THREE
THROUGH. SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
. PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS I'D ACTUALLY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE QUORUM CALL REMAINS IN PLACE
QUORUM CALL REMAINS IN PLACE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. WE ARE
DETERMINED TO MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE ANY CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK. ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. DR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A BELOVED
CONSTITUENT DR DOROTHY SMITH WHO
TRANSITION THIS MONTH ON
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY TWO. DR SMITH
WITH A LONGTIME EDUCATOR SERVING
AS THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN ON THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD
OF EDUCATION AND THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN TO HOLD ELECTED POSITION
IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO. SHE'S
ARE FOR EIGHT YEARS ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD INCLUDING TWICE AS
PRESIDENT. WITH THE KING FOCUSED
ON ELEVATING THE QUALITY AND
EQUITY OF EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS
. IN HER OWN WORDS DR SMITH
SAID. EDUCATION IS THE PATHWAY
TO FREEDOM. SHE HAD A LOVE AND
PASSION FOR CHILDREN EDUCATION
AND MENTORSHIP. SHE GREW UP IN
THE JIM CROW SOUTH BEFORE MOVING
TO SAN DIEGO. SHE BECAME A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTRUCTOR AT
GROWTH MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND
THEN SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS. ONE OF THE
COURSES SHE CREATED WITH CALLED
BLACK WOMEN IN LITERATURE AND
MEDIA WHICH CONTINUES TO BE
CAUGHT. IN THE CENTER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT FOR MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE YEARS. SHE WAS A
LECTURER AND TEACHER EDUCATION
AND RHETORIC AND WRITING AT
SENEGAL STATE UNIVERSITY. AND
SERVED AS THE FIRST DIRECTOR OF
THE UNIVERSITY'S AIM TO TEACH
PROGRAM WHERE SHE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE DIVERSITY OF
STUDENTS AND TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM. SHE WAS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE COMMON
GROUND THE OLDEST BLACK THEATER
IN SAN DIEGO. AND AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA
SORORITY INCORPORATED. IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE DOCTOR SMITH WAS
APPOINTED AS ONE OF FIVE
INAUGURAL MEMBERS OF THE SAN
DIEGO ETHICS COMMISSION. AND
SERVICE TWO YEARS AS PRESIDENT.
AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN SHE WAS
ONE OF FIVE WOMEN INDUCTED INTO
SAN DIEGO WOMEN'S HALL OF FAME
AND THE TRAILBLAZER CATEGORY FOR
HER REMARKABLE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
STEADFASTNESS AND THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY. DR DOROTHY SMITH WILL
BE DEEPLY MISSED SHE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND CARL SMITH. SUN
DR CARLTON SMITH DAUGHTER SHARON
LOT AND GRANDCHILDREN EVAN LOT
LAUREN LOT RENDON MILAN AND
CARLTON SMITH THE SECOND. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE DR SMITH MADE SURE
THAT THE DOOR SHE OPENED IN SAN
DIEGO POLITICS FOR BLACK WOMEN
WOULD REMAIN OPEN. WHEN SHE WAS
TURNING OUT OF THE SANTA UNIFIED
SCHOOL BOARD SHE ENCOURAGED A
NOTHER DYNAMIC EDUCATOR TO RUN
AND FILL HER SEAT. THAT PERSON
WAS DR SHIRLEY WEBER. OUR
CURRENT SECRETARY OF STATE AND
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS BODY. DR
DOROTHY SMITH IMPACT ON BLACK
POLITICS ESPECIALLY IN BLACK
FEMALE ELECTED TO SERVE SAN
DIEGO WERE PROCESS FOR
GENERATIONS AS THOSE OF US WHO
NOW SERVES WILL COMMIT TO
KEEPING DOORS OPEN. AND
CONTINUING SHATTERING GLASS
CEILINGS THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
WEBER. INVESTORS SAY OUR CO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR AND YOUR
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ASK THAT
WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A
LEASE YEAH NEVADA SOSA. PLEASE
YES ALSO PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH AT THE REMARKABLE
AGE OF A HUNDRED AND EIGHT. HE
WAS BORN IN TIJUANA MEXICO IN
NINETEEN FOURTEEN DURING THE
MEXICAN REVOLUTION PELISSIER WAS
ORPHANED AT AN EARLY AGE IN LIFE
. AFTER MOVING TO LOS ANGELES
WITH HER AUNT LISA STUDIED AND
BECAME A LICENSED. COSMETOLOGIST
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN. BY THE
TIME SHE WAS NINETEEN IT OPENED
HER OWN SALON ART SALON AND- AND
EMPLOYED SIX PEOPLE. WHILE
RUNNING HER SALON SHE TOOK A
BREAK WENT DOWN TO MEXICO AND
SHE MET A STANISLAUS SOSA WHO
WORKED ON THE RAILROAD. AND THEY
WERE MARRIED AND BOUGHT A HOME
IN MIDTOWN LOS ANGELES. THEY
RAISE THEIR TWO SONS AND ONE
DAUGHTER AND ENJOYED A WONDERFUL
SIXTY YEAR MARRIAGE BEFORE
STANISLAV PASSED AWAY. HER LOVE
OF COMMUNITY BECAUSE YOU'RE TO
BE CENTRAL DEMANDING VOTING
PRECINCTS HE ALSO PARTICIPATED
IN THOSE. AND WHEN SHE TURNED A
HUNDRED YEARS OLD SHE RECEIVED
NOT ONLY A LETTER FROM PRESIDENT
BUSH BEEN ANOTHER LETTER FROM
PRESIDENT OBAMA. WHICH SHE HELD
ONTO WITH IMMENSE PRIDE. THROUGH
HER CAN DO ATTITUDE POLICE
CONSTANTLY ESPOUSE THE VALUE OF
HARD WORK WITH A LIFE MOTTO.
WILL TAILOR BY HINA WHICH MEANS
TURN THE PAGE MOVE ON. IT IS
AMAZING TO IMAGINE HER LIFE AND
HER EXPERIENCE SO MUCH IN
HISTORY IN THAT HUNDRED EIGHT
YEARS. SHE GOT A SEAT TO
PANDEMICS THE SPANISH FLU AND
COBIT TWO WORLD WARS THE GREAT
DEPRESSION. NOT TO MENTION THE
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENT IN THOSE HUNDRED IN
EIGHT YEARS. OF GOING TO THE
MOON PEOPLE GOING FROM HORSES TO
AUTOMOBILES. AND COMPUTERS AND
MEDICAL SCIENCE. AS AN IMMIGRANT
TO THIS COUNTRY AT LEAST YES
ALSO TRULY BECAME A TRUE MORAL
TRUE ROLE MODEL TO ALL OF THOSE
WHO SHE CAME ACROSS. HE RAISED A
LOVING AND PRODUCTIVE FAMILY.
WITH SELF MADE AND LIVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM. HER FRIENDS
INCLUDED PEOPLE FROM ALL
CULTURES RACES FAITHS AND
LIFESTYLES. GEN BRACED ALL WITH
OPEN ARMS AND LEFT A REMARKABLE
LEGISLATOR LEGIS LEGACY. MEMBERS
I THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY AND AGAIN I ASKED
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A LEASE
YEAH NEVADA SOSA. THANK YOU.
THANK GOODNESS SHARE TELL. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DAVIES CELEBRATED HER BIRTHDAY
YESTERDAY WHEN YOU SEE MISS
DAVIES WISH HER HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
AND OUR NEWEST MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG HIS BIRTHDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINTH. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AS FAR. MY CHILDREN
LOVE CAMANO. BRAINY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG. THERE
ARE MULTIPLE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON. BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ONE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT WE'LL ALL MEET. AT
TWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
TO. ED BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FIVE
pTWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM. FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. SESSION SCHEDULE.
SESSION. WEDNESDAY MARCH SECOND-
FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION. THURSDAY MARCH THIRD
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION TO QUORUM
CALL IS NOW LIFTED. ALL OTHER
ITEMS RATING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS ARE READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
BIZRATE'S MOOSE MR LACKEY THE
SECOND SET THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH
THE THIRD. AT NINE AM. WE ARE
JOURNAL.